to the starting line I'm out shopping
and I see something strange I can't
believe my eyes
I'm walking behind this thing isn't even
that samsung galaxy is I highlight shall
eat a gala for the thing offers to show
me around the store great just to follow
me the virtual bird is my digital
shopping assistant it doesn't know much
yet but it learns quickly soon it'll
recognize customers and their
preferences it's about to realize I'm
not at all interested in household
appliances stops are vacuum cleaner are
you serious
now he forced Ellen Dyson kinetic big
bulge stops Olga maybe in the future
you'll walk into a store and will
already know what you've come for
if the customer wants us to we could
offer targeted product maybe ones who
don't know yet but would like ten I
would begin out through in passing
Verdun so do you like it stops Olga no
to be honest
I get the feeling I'm just listening to
advertising
I wonder who programs the digital
assistant and who decides what the
customer gets recommended
[Music]
when does customer service become
product marketing
[Music]
lots of questions but at least it was
very entertaining
I don't believe it we're trying out a
lot of different things in a short
period of time it will learn to
introduce new products you can even
include special offers we'll just have
to see what works best with the
customers and then build on that what
about advertising money from the
companies like maybe I don't want to
rule it out
but the focus is really on making things
easier for the customers and the staff
the future lies in the hands of the
programmers
I'm your Google assistant I can help you
find answers get things done and have
fun digitalization changes our habits
life is moving faster and faster for
budding entrepreneurs that opens up a
lot of great opportunities and there's
plenty of room in Berlin for fresh ideas
and new startups
[Music]
like in 26 the first German digital Bank
but this doesn't look like a financial
institution with an official banking
license would I feel comfortable keeping
my money here Valentin shells one of the
founders explains how I can open an
account on my smartphone in just 8
minutes just logged in with my
fingerprint as you see I'm really quite
overdrawn and I can see all the
transactions here I can tell how much I
spent on shopping for example and decide
if it was too much I have an exact
overview of what I spent transfers
investments even getting a loan it's all
possible with just a few clicks banking
we call it real-time banking if I pay
for something with my credit card I get
an immediate notification on my
smartphone people want to be in control
of their finances and you get that if
you can see what you spend in that
moment rather than on a monthly bill
people want banking to be uncomplicated
and possible from anywhere sounds good
but the digital bank is also collecting
lots of valuable customer data
algorithms take away in the background
analyzing and learning who we are
[Music]
in the supermarket how long when I spend
my money can still be completely
anonymous
I can pay in cash to a real person but
digital customer service is on its way
I'm proudly showing the first steps in
this super market a product finder if
you're looking for something in
particular you can enter the product
here then search and you'll be navigated
there then of course there's still lots
of advertising petrol prices and baking
recipes but technology has much more to
offer to find out what let's take a look
at the supermarket of the future I'm
here at the German Research Center for
artificial intelligence the food in here
is made of plastic
a sensor determines if everything's in
the right place the customer receives
additional information up here a
practice run with head of research Spann
Goering I take a look at the smart meat
counter which can tell what I'm pointing
at
[Music]
then against the camera the camera
hanging over the counter recognizes the
position of your arm it calculates the
extension of the arm into the counter
because the system knows ahead of time
we'll learn where in the counter the
products are it can easily figure out
what you're pointing at information of
that is probably tagging the shopping
cart keeps track of what's in it and of
course we make a cash free payment via
an app there are still places in Germany
without internet or mobile coverage I'm
on my way to sure NAR mark a village
north of Berlin with about 300 residents
vacationers come here in search of peace
and quiet for example by taking a stroll
with the donkeys
[Music]
a very important aspect of these walks
is that the guests use a map and not
Wi-Fi or a route planner because they
have no cell phone reception they have
to run together and they have to read
the map because cell phones don't work
here since Watson would consciously
getting offline and unwinding that's a
tourist business around here they're
very soft fellow is really old but he's
nice to cuddle there are so many people
who need that yeah we mention Holcomb
for my they want to pet something gosh
yes petting and cuddling many people
miss that from this insane fall the
donkeys offer a kind of digital detox a
way of combating stress just shut down
your Facebook and experience real life
digna do you tie do you eat I think
going on a digital diet is important but
many people don't realize you have the
chance to start here it's important to
realize that going without is fine it's
doable and then see how far you can take
it I feel like I've really slowed down
for one afternoon
I've left my digital life far behind me
[Music]
now I'll try to open the virtual door
for someone like that country village
this place is all about digital
experiences
it's like really being inside a car any
problems on our cabinets an order the
gearstick should be around here
somewhere
engine gamma can't meet me you can
certainly self offer the customer a lot
more extras with this system of unbeaten
in Kandahar feeding file it's the car
companies pilot project virtual reality
could soon be standard practice when
buying a car I just have one problem the
headset makes me dizzy
so it's let's stop for now I never
thought I'd be so sensitive I also get
dizzy when I see how digitalization has
changed our lives and shopping is just
the tip of the iceberg
you
[Music]